hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm
checking out the trailer for let's see
here the revenant Leonardo DiCaprio Tom
Hardy that right there is an orgasmic
cast let's do this
[Music]
Wow
and that is beautiful
[Music]
already
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
plus the director of Babel
[Music]
see
[Music]
Wow like real stuntmen in this movie
holy [ __ ]
that looks [ __ ] intense first off
shot [ __ ] beautifully DiCaprio looks
like he's gonna give a solid performance
again this guy's just loved DiCaprio
[ __ ] love DiCaprio I mean he looks
intense the those action sequences
though like the action sequences like
that the takes go on and you could tell
these are like the guy falls from a tree
onto the snow and then the dude falls
off his horse like the stunts look very
real this looks like one of those films
I was probably like a pain in the ass to
[ __ ] make it's from the director of
Babel I have pretty sure it is I like
Babel a lot it schooled Brad Pitt was in
that and he's done a few other projects
since then but it's cool to see him
returning to a film that's probably
gonna be a big studio hit hopefully I
mean this doesn't look like a typical
studio film but it's from 20th Century
Fox has Tom Hardy in it you know you
don't really get much of Tom Hardy in
this trailer but just from the few
glimpses we get we can tell he's doing
another character again I mean DiCaprio
due to me and everyone just keeps
talking about how he still hasn't got it
an Oscar yet maybe he'll get a
nomination for this I don't know if he's
gonna win or not this could be the type
of performance that does win him an
Oscar but it's not about that it's about
rocking a [ __ ] good movie and being a
great character actor so did you see
trailer man because it shows nothing
about the story it just shows tone and
style and I still got like chills from
it this is an interesting landscape to
look at it's wilderness and the snow it
looks [ __ ] awesome it looks gritty it
looks like it's gonna be [ __ ] violent
I mean it kind of is like reminiscent of
man in the wilderness with Richard
Harris I I don't think this is a remake
I highly doubt it but it does seem
reminiscent of that man cool [ __ ]
trailer two minutes of Leonardo DiCaprio
taking deep breaths [ __ ] awesome
I'd like him to take deep breaths on me
you know what I mean anyway guys thanks
for tuning in if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope
because if we get enough followers we
can get even more product placement for
things such as keychains keychains are
great sometimes you're looking through
your keys don't know which one's gonna
work but
keychain will help define it the first
time I had sex the girl had a chastity
belt on and she gave me the ring I had
to put a key chain around it it looked
like a vagina the keychain and I when I
put it in actually the key didn't work
she gave me the wrong keys so I never
even had sex with her his wasn't the
first time I had sex first time I almost
had sex
actually that was a night time I've
almost had sex I still haven't had sex
key chains